Oh Jane we're actually not moving today
because my husband just came back from
the dead you don't know though it's
actually Michael we're in for some big
surprises with Jane the Virgin and while
Michael may have returned from the dead
Gina Rodriguez assures us that the cast
is keeping their bond alive when he
walked into the table room wasn't just
like a ghost what was that experience
like I was definitely pale I didn't see
Sun for a while he did it he did it he's
a method actor it felt like my heart
sank because he's one of my best friends
in real life we had a little warning
before him uh we all had a sneaking
suspicion that he was coming back I
would say Michael is back exactly but
the good thing is the good thing is the
fans that story thing is gonna get
resolved at first two minutes of the
first episode of season five so that's
good it's not gonna be it's not gonna be
like a cliffhanger that will hang
forever
we make a really good team Rafael had
everything he had ever wanted like in
his hands and then Michael came back so
it creates a big massive conflict and
Rafael's gonna be faced with making some
pretty difficult choices how are you
gonna shake things up for Jane and
Rafael that relationship with something
that was solid I mean he's right play
with everyone's feelings I'm gonna have
all the feelings in my hand I'm just
gonna rip them apart and I'm so excited
I'm gonna rip it and everyone's gonna
cry super soft and gentle he's not gonna
do that
it's gonna make something no not at all
but thanks for getting my back here cuz
that could have been bad
hey you okay you know me so well who are
you rooting for now we have these love
triangle like as you very well know and
in real fans know that people get
confused they think of those love
stories between Raphael and Jane or
Michael and Jane when your reality the
love stories between Aurelio and Michael
exactly so now that Michael is that
finally fine Michael is back finally the
real love story of the show can evolve
you're gonna think it's because I don't
think you should marry Rafael which is
true but that's not why I'm reminding
you as Jane's mom so who is she want her
daughter to end up with I've always been
and I remain a team Michael you know I
mean as a mom you know you would want a
guy who was stuck with your daughter
through thick and thin
and really terrible really knows what it
is to earn money you know he's a hard
work yeah and you know but I mean
nothing against Raphael / Justin cuz I
love Justin in real life nothing but
with a new dynamic of Michael having
amnesia does that change things for you
but definitely has I have new lenses for
the Raphael character for sure
he's definitely won my heart those heart
much more than it was maybe in the first
three seasons so it's hard to say I mean
they're both great guys James very very
lucky lady you're going to be surprised
and it's going to Jane is going to have
a happy ending
nobody knows what that endings going to
look like well fans get the closure that
we deserve though yes yes right right
with you - yes
[Music]
[Applause]